c'était ce matin la fin d'un chantier de
réhabilitation de 85 logements sociaux
attrape une réalisation qui s'inscrit
dans un grand projet de rénovation
urbaine de la ville
ouvrir un certain nombre de rues ou de
chemins piétons kif qui font que les
grand îlot qui avait été conçu dans les
années 70 80 soit morceau laisse vivre
en paix puisent l'eau qui permet temps
d'une part aux gens d'accéder d'avoir
une adresse
et puis qui permet aussi aux services de
secours aux services de sécurité au
service d'entretien d'avoir des accès
beaucoup plus facile ce chantier est
innovant à plus d'un titre et a été
plusieurs fois primé installation de
panneaux voltaïques et solaire isolation
thermique par des éléments de façade en
bois chauffage collectif au gaz
tout a été conçu pour réduire les
consommations d'énergie as un bon
exemple de ce qu'on peut faire c'est
innovant c'est c'est raisonnable en
termes de coût et en qualité de vie à
l'intérieur d'une habitation
c'est ses partisans positive les
logements et les parties communes ont pu
également bénéficier de petits travaux
de réfection les locataires ont pu
rester chez eux pendant tous les travaux
elles ont fait le ravalement la cuisine
l'étoile est étirée la salle de bain des
matériaux de qualité avec l'utilisation
du bois des délais raccourcis un coût
maîtrisé et une résidence capable de
produire une partie de son énergie
un exemple qui devrait servir de modèle
pour les nombreux projets de
réhabilitation en attente dans la région